la france est un état unitaire ça veut
dire que tous les citoyens sont soumis
aux mêmes pouvoirs souverains
présent dans la capitale mais même si le
pouvoir central en france vient de paris
en regardant une carte on voit bien
qu'il existe des régions de départements
des communes et d'autres plus petits
partis de territoire qu'on appelle des
collectivités territoriales mais du coup
c'est quoi une collectivité territoriale
une collectivité territoriale qu'on
appelait avant aussi collectivités
locales est un bout de territoire
relativement autonome par rapport à
l'état qui possède ses propres
compétences
il existe en france 13 régions sans un
département plus de 35000 commune cinq
collectivités d'outre-mer et enfin il
existe aussi quelques exceptions comme
les grandes métropoles telles que paris
marseille ou lyon où la nouvelle
calédonie qui possède des règles un peu
différente
le but des collectivités territoriales
est simple prendre en charge les
intérêts de la population d'un
territoire précis les orientations et
actions de la collectivité territoriale
sont pris en charge par un conseil dé
lui conseil municipalle conseil régional
conseil départemental et c'est comme ces
conseils ne sont pas nommés par le
pouvoir central
mais élu par les habitants ils peuvent
garder une plus grande indépendance et
liberté d'agir
les collectivités territoriales peuvent
collecter des impôts est géré librement
leur budget c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'autonomie financière
les collectivités territoriales peuvent
aussi se représenter seul devant la
justice en tant que personne morale ont
dit qu'elles ont une autonomie juridique
c'est la loi qui définit les compétences
des collectivités territoriales de façon
précise et spécialisés et les
collectivités territoriales doivent
respecter la constitution les lois et
les règlements au dessus d'elle
l'état ne peut pas prendre le contrôle
d'une collectivité territoriale est une
collectivité territoriale ne peut pas
prendre le pouvoir sur une autre les
collectivités territoriales ne possède
que des compétences administratives
elle ne peut pas avoir les mêmes
compétences qu'un état comme créer des
lois ou des règlements autonome faire la
justice où se mêler de la diplomatie
internationale
[Musique]
nous détaillerons plus précisément les
rôles et les compétences de chacune des
collectivités territoriales dans une
prochaine vidéo
mais pour le moment j'espère que vous
comprenez mieux ce qu'est une
collectivité territoriale
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
retrouvez nous sur les différents
réseaux sociaux n'hésitez pas à laisser
un commentaire
et en poussant l'air à très bientôt